[Music]
startling dash cam footage out of Toledo
Ohio showed the moments a man swerves
and crashes into an elementary school
but it doesn't end there the crash
suspect later tries to escape from a
police
[Music]
vehicle dash cam video showed the
pursuit of the suspect after he failed
to comply during a traffic stop police
say the driver who was later identified
as Ryan hasselbach was traveling at
speeds of 90 to 100 mph before losing
control of his truck and crashing into
an elementary school after the crash
hasselbach is handcuffed and put into
the back of a squad car have a seat in
the back man I understand that you
know it's called they got
balls real balls on you
bud once the door shut footage from
inside the police vehicle showed a
handcuffed hassle Bo tried to slide the
handcuffs around the lower part of his
body
a minute passes by still undeterred
hasselbach keeps attempting his Escape
while you can hear officers speaking to
one another in the
background I got lane theer lane and
come back out
Lane
going
behind
one from gas
station
got
moments later hasselbach speaks to the
officers outside the vehicle although
they seem unaware of Hassel Box's
attempts to
flee okay so is he being compliant or is
he just
drk no I'm very compliant I can hear
everything you're
saying it doesn't make any less of an
idiot oh yeah yeah
sure
Hassel Baka addresses the officers again
to tell them his side of the story about
the moments leading up to the
crash all right well and he reeks his
alcohol he's got glossy bloodshot eyes
on yeah I'd have glossy bloody shot eyes
when I'm hitting a school cuz I'm being
chased by the police for no reason if
you stop you won't be chased you realize
that yeah if I were to stop then I get a
fine too much that I can't
afford because the government is always
trying to pay off my money an officer
then reads A visibly intoxicated
hasselbach his Miranda writes at this
point you have the right to remain
silent anything you say can will be used
against you in a court of law you have
the right to talk to a lawyer and have
him or her present with you while you
are being questioned you Cann afford to
hire a lawyer one will be represent one
will be appointed to represent you
before any questioning if you wish you
can decide at any time time to exercise
these rights and not answer any
questions or make any statements do you
understand these rights that I've read
to you yes sir okay an officer again
shuts the police vehicle door on
hasselbach who again attempts to free
himself from his
handcuffs after removing his shoes while
handcuffed hasselbach slips his
handcuffs from behind his back to in
front of his body giving himself an
easier way to make his Escape but he
keeps his hands near his feet and out of
sight from officers another minute
passes as hasselbach reaches for the
door
while making his attempt hasselbach then
appears to stop as an officer outside of
the vehicle ask him more questions Mr
hasselbach are you willing to submit to
a blood draw
tonight um sure okay Co it appears the
officers are unaware that hasselbach is
without his shoes and his handcuffs are
in front of his body hasselbach again
tries to get out of the police car
seconds later hobok gets closer to his
goal as he appears to get the door open
with police
unaware
[Music]
is
then hasselbach can be seen putting his
shoes back on and attempting to get out
of the police car yet again
hasselbach sees one of the officers get
into the driver's seat the officer
unaware hasselbach is attempting to flee
back yes sir the police car then takes
off from the crash site presumably to
take hasselbach to jail but hasselbach
still appears determined to make his
Escape
[Music]
Ryan hasselbach was later charged with
vandalism of a government entity failure
to comply with an order obstructing
official business and charges of
operating a vehicle Under the Influence
Ryan Hassel was treated for minor
injuries the crash reportedly cost an
estimated
$150,000 in Damages reporting for the
law crime Network I'm Elizabeth Milner